Narrator: These are the Sharks.
They have achieved incredible
success as entrepreneurs
and investors
in multiple sectors.
They all came
from humble beginnings
and are all self‐made.
The Sharks know what it takes
to build business empires
from nothing into billions.
Now they are investing
in entrepreneurs' dreams.
Together we can crush
the competition.
Wow!
Yay!
She knows cash flow
when she sees it.
I know your history. I know what
you're capable of doing.
Oh!
At any given time,
a Shark can turn
into a bottom‐feeding catfish.
[ Grunts ]
Narrator: This is the art
of doing business.
Should I beat you up now
or should we wait?
This is "Shark Tank."
What am I gonna do?
[ Grunting ]
♪♪
O'Leary: Let's do this.
Narrator: First into the Tank
is what
the entrepreneur believes
is a better way
to keep things cool.
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Stan Efferding.
My company is The Kooler.
And I'm asking for $50,000 in
exchange for 15% of my company.
I'm an IFBB
professional body builder
and world‐record power lifter
known throughout the industry
as the White Rhino.
[ Scattered laughter ]
And I'm the reigning
title holder
of the Mr. Olympia's World's
Strongest Pro Bodybuilder.
Cuban: Dang.
I've been training
amateur
and professional athletes
for over 25 years,
and I tell my athletes,
if you want to press
a 200‐pound dumbbell overhead...
[ Grunting ]
‐Oh, ho!
‐Oh, my God!
[ Laughter ]
Herjavec: Wow!
Yeah!
‐Oh!
‐Oh, Lord!
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Hup!
[ Grunts ]
[ Laughs ]
...then you'd better get
proper nutrition
before your workout,
and if you want
to dead‐lift 600 pounds...
What?
Hup!
[ Grunts ]
Ahh.
[ Bang ]
‐Holy crap.
‐Oh, my God.
...then you'd better
stay hydrated.
And if you want to flip
an 800‐pound tire...
[ Grunting ]
Hup! Ay! Up! Up! Up! Up! Up!
‐Bam!
‐Blow it up!
[ Laughter ]
...then you'd better get
plenty of protein
to recover from your workout.
That's why I invented
The Kooler.
It's the world's only
cooler within a cooler.
First, it's a double‐wall
insulated cooler
that holds a gallon of ice water
that you can drink
while exercising
or throughout the day.
If you want a protein shake
or an energy drink
while you're training,
here you go.
Ice cold.
If you want a snack or
a meal‐replacement drink after,
The Kooler comes
with a second shaker bottle.
I designed it to hold some
protein or carbohydrate powder
for your
post‐exercise nutrition.
Now, remember,
the ice water goes in here,
and when the shakers go in,
the water keeps them cold.
The Kooler keeps
three drinks all together
inside one ice‐cold container.
So, what do you say, Sharks?
You won't find a "cooler"
business for your investment.
Together, we can crush
the competition.
[ Laughter ]
I have some samples.
Robert, for you and Lori.
‐Hey.
‐Thank you.
‐Yeah.
‐Wow, these aren't even heavy.
‐Thank you, Stan.
‐Mr. Wonderful.
Thank you.
I can really see this applying
to heavy‐duty lifting people
'cause they always have
the protein shakes,
they always have
the water.
It's a lot
of containers.
But do you see it
as a wide product?
I think the average guy
would use it,
because I ‐‐ I notice
the average guys in
the gyms all the time
with their gym bags are loaded
with multiple different drinks.
You know, first of all,
the average girl
should be included here.
That's a good point.
But when you think
universally about a product,
you want to have it
be convenient
for a broad, mass audience
because that's how you're
gonna get better sales.
Not necessarily.
O'Leary:
Listen, White Rhino...
Wait. I don't ‐‐ Wait.
...I sense a little skepticism
amongst the Sharks.
Excuse me.
But you could
blow that away
by telling us
you've sold a lot of them.
Well, I've been 16 months
on the market.
I've sold $120,000 worth
of product.
How did you sell them?
‐That's not bad.
‐That's not bad at all.
I have a national distributor,
the largest one in the country.
It has seven
regional warehouses,
and they supply
over 30,000 locations.
What kind of locations?
General Nutrition Center,
Vitamin Shoppe,
mom‐and‐pop nutrition stores.
Have you been selling any
online?
I am.
Half of my sales are online.
What do you
sell it for?
I pay $7.
I sell it for $32.95.
So you've made some
decent money off of this.
It pays for itself.
I break even thus far on
an aggressive travel schedule.
I've traveled all over
the country to expos ‐‐
So you're going
to all the different shows?
Yes.
When I go to the expos,
I expect bodybuilders
and power lifters
to come up
and buy my product.
But I find that
over half of the consumers
are moms and dads, children,
police officers, and firemen
who are on the road.
O'Leary: You're telling me
a soccer mom will buy this?
Absolutely.
There's 30 million kids
a year
that sign up
for kids' sports.
Cuban: Stan, what's been
your biggest challenge?
Why haven't you sold
a million dollars worth
as opposed to $120,000?
My biggest challenge is
when it sits on the shelf
at a store,
you can't tell what it is
or what it does.
Right.
I have
to touch every customer,
and what I want to do now
is I want to try and utilize
either an infomercial
or a QVC‐style presentation
to talk to those soccer moms,
to show them
the benefits of the product
so I can reach
thousands of people at once.
What's your background?
Do you have any other
businesses you've run?
I do.
It might be easy to judge
this book by its cover.
Ha!
But I've turned
three startup companies
into multimillion‐dollar
businesses.
And I started
an engineering firm.
Last year, we did $5 million
in gross sales.
Now, I became a silent partner
in that firm
a year and a half ago
so I could focus full‐time
on The Kooler.
You know, White Rhino,
you're an impressive guy.
When you first
walked out here,
I thought,
"Okay, meathead guy."
But you've got
a really good background.
Love the passion,
and I like what you've done.
And you're ‐‐ you're
the brand kind of thing.
But it's extremely vertical
and niche‐y.
I don't think
I'm gonna make any money.
I like you, White Rhino ‐‐
I really do ‐‐ but I'm out.
Thank you,
Mr. Wonderful.
Cuban: Here's what
I see, Stan.
It's a good idea.
You know how to sell it.
But what's missing
is an accelerant.
I don't see what
that accelerant is.
It's gonna take your
hand‐to‐hand combat to sell it.
That's a problem for me,
and so for those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
When I invest
in a product,
I like something that I can
sell to all my customers.
This is very, very niche.
You spoke about, it's great
for an infomercial.
The thing a lot of people
don't understand is,
is that infomercials
are extremely difficult.
9 out of 10 fail.
This, on QVC,
because of your audience,
which I think is much more
sports‐oriented,
and that I don't see as a heavy
QVC‐watching audience.
I'm sorry.
I'm out.
Herjavec:
I see the opposite.
I think you're trying
to make a niche product
and appeal
to too wide a base.
I wish
it was more hard‐core.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Daymond,
that leaves you and me,
and I need help carrying
this tire out of here,
so we got to make a deal.
[ Laughs ]
I know it definitely
doesn't look like it,
but I have a lot to do
with fitness.
‐Where?
‐Really?
Yeah.
I just sold my CrossFit.
I work with bodybuild‐‐
'Cause you don't look
like White Rhino.
‐Huh?
‐You're the reverse.
You're the inverse.
[ Laughs ] Yeah.
[ Greiner laughs ]
Are you saying
Daymond's the "before"?
‐[ Laughs ] Yeah.
‐I think so.
Yeah.
Um...
All right, I'm gonna make you
an offer, but...
[ Exhales ] So...
But here it comes.
$50,000 for 15%...
Are you sure you want
to make the White Rhino mad?
O'Leary:
Could get ugly here.
Yeah.
Okay, so,
I'll give you $50,000
for a third
of the company.
I think
that's a fair offer.
But before I make
a final decision,
I do have to ask
the big guns.
Guys, what do you think?
[ Laughter ]
Daymond, you got a deal.
All right.
[ Applause ]
Congrats, White Rhino.
Thank you.
Just don't squeeze me, man.
‐Making him happy.
‐Okay.
All right.
I think I made a great deal.
Daymond understands
the industry.
He understood the product.
He knows the players.
So it was an easy match.
What we know now is
the White Rhino has
a new partner ‐‐
the Black Rhino.
[ Laughter ]
And let me tell you
something else.
We're never gonna have
a disagreement.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Narrator: Next up
is a stylish version
of a common kids' product.
[ Baby cooing ]
[ Chuckles ]
[ Cooing continues ]
Look at those eyes.
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Elizabeth Granados,
and I live in West Hartford,
Connecticut,
with my husband, Jeremiah,
and my daughter, Talia.
I'm here seeking $80,000
for 15% of my company,
Little Nomad.
Granados: When my
super‐stylish BFF, Marissa,
invited me over
to check out her new home,
I knew I'd be impressed.
She's one of the most
stylish mamas I know,
which is why I was
literally horrified
to see these tacky,
circus‐colored foam play mats
all over the floor
in her living room.
Now, to be fair to Marissa...
‐[ Shrieking ]
‐Shh.
...her decision to use
foam flooring was,
in fact,
quite practical.
[ Laughs ]
It protects her little ones
from bumps and bruises.
It's water‐resistant.
Aww.
It's easy to clean.
So, right there
in Marissa's living room,
I had my "aha" moment ‐‐
to make foam beautiful.
Watch as we transform
this eyesore
into a gorgeous,
peaceful playspace.
Uncle Wonderful, would you mind
babysitting Talia for a moment?
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Kids love me.
Greiner: She's gonna
start crying.
John: Why do you think
she's crying?
[ Laughter ]
Don't be scared.
‐Aww. Hi.
‐Hi.
[ Laughter ]
Yay!
She knows cash flow
when she sees it.
[ Laughter ]
Introducing Little Nomad ‐‐
beautifully illustrated,
printed play mats.
It looks
like an heirloom rug
you might spend
thousands of dollars on.
But, nope, it's a practical,
wipe‐clean, foam play mat.
They're great for crawling.
They're also great
for tummy time,
learning to sit up,
and easy to clean.
We also have some customers
who have said
the mats are great for other
uses throughout their home,
including under
their standing desk,
as soft flooring
in their kitchen,
or even as an exercise mat.
So, Sharks, which one of you
want to help me
drive the circus out of town
and bring some serenity
into the homes
of stylish parents everywhere?
All right.
So, Talia ‐‐
I think she needs a nap,
so we're gonna say bye,
and I'm gonna hand out samples.
Too bad she has to leave
so early.
Greiner: Bye.
I was gonna teach her
all about money.
[ Laughs ]
Granados:
I do have some swatches
so that you can
feel the quality close up.
‐Thank you.
Yeah,
and take one of each color.
Thank you.
I currently have one pattern
in the two colors.
Yeah, thank you, guys.
What is the plan for getting
distribution for this?
So ‐‐
Well, let's hear about
the sales first.
Greiner: Yeah,
let's hear your sales.
Okay, so, I've been in business
for 3 1/2 months.
I've pre‐sold $114,000 worth
of play mats.
‐Wow.
‐Nice.
Good for you. But you haven't
shipped anything yet.
My product will ship
in November.
It's currently
being manufactured.
And what did you do
to market?
We Photoshopped together a
picture ‐‐ the designer and I ‐‐
and I started sharing that
on Facebook mom groups,
directed them
to a landing page
where I got
their e‐mail address.
Good for you.
I collected 4,555 e‐mails.
‐Wow.
‐Moms are going nuts.
Where would you want to be
with this product?
I would love to align with
the right retail stores ‐‐
Buy Buy Baby,
Nordstrom, Giggle.
Do you sell it
as a package?
Yes.
I sell them as a set of six.
They're 2 feet by 2 feet,
plus 12 edges.
‐Got it.
‐So it's a seamless connection.
And how much are you ‐‐ how much
are you making this for?
Yeah,
what's your margin?
It's $16.39 to manufacture,
and once they're here,
my plan is to sell them
for $139.
You're definitely
at the high end
for this product.
Yeah, there's a range
from about $35 to $149.
We're not
the highest price.
Cuban: There's nothing
wrong with that.
You don't have to be
the cheapest.
Yeah.
With that kind of margin,
why not just continue
to sell them all online?
Yeah, that's
incredible margin.
Well, here's why ‐‐
As someone who just had a baby,
I know that the registry is key.
All right.
When you came in here,
you had your competitor
on the floor.
Yep.
And your basic premise
for building this business
was the competitor's product
is garish and ugly
if you don't like
bright colors.
Yes.
But it's also half the price
of yours, right?
I figure I should know
why I'm paying twice as much.
Wait. Stop, stop.
The foam is the best‐quality
foam I could buy.
And is your foam safer
than other foams?
Yes.
We've had our mats tested,
and they're safety rated
for zero months‐plus.
They are non‐toxic.
But that's not why
you're buying it, right?
You're buying it
for the look.
If it's true you're
buying it for the look,
why doesn't the guy
that makes the cheap foam...
Just make
a bland version?
I got to tell you,
Elizabeth,
how many families other than
the Upper East Side of New York
want to spend 150 bucks ‐‐
So far, 1,000 moms
throughout the U. S.,
and I've been at this
for such a short amount of time.
People love it.
You don't want to make
hundreds of dollars.
You want to make
millions of dollars.
I do.
So why don't you
bring the price down?
So you have to appeal
to a bigger market.
That's ‐‐ That's a big number
for somebody with a child,
who has to buy diapers
and everything else.
Then, even when I had
a play mat, it was ‐‐
My mother found an old
refrigerator box, cut it open.
I played on it
for 10 years,
and then when I was 18,
I went outside
and broke‐danced on it.
So, yes, it's $139,
but it's not something you want
to immediately get rid of.
I ‐‐ I just ‐‐
I don't think 95% of the county
can afford that.
Stay with me, Daymond.
Please.
I'm out.
So, Elizabeth,
you've done such a great job
to get to this point,
but you didn't talk anything
about doubling down
on what's working for you
online.
I will continue
to sell online.
You said,
"I'm gonna take that money,
I'm gonna go retail."
This giant piece
of inventory
is not gonna find its way
to a retailer.
It takes up
too much space.
Why go retail at all?
Well, that's what
I want to know because ‐‐
They're ridiculous.
They always say that.
And that's where
you have no problem going.
Elizabeth, have you heard
the story of Ulysses,
very famous
Greek mythology?
[ Chuckles ]
He was
a very great captain,
and the biggest risk
he and his sailors
always worried about
were the Sirens that
would sing from the rocks,
and they were
so sweet in music
that he asked his men to tie him
to the mast and blindfold him
so he wouldn't guide
his ship into the rocks.
It was retailers on the rocks,
calling him in...
[ Laughter ]
...trying to get Ulysses
to come in for retail deals.
Look, Kevin ‐‐
And he knew.
I know that Buy Buy Baby,
Nordstrom ‐‐
these are where
the stylish moms are registered,
and that's my ‐‐
that's my strategy,
just to get it
onto the baby registries.
At the end of the day ‐‐
But there's a progression,
Elizabeth.
There's
a progression.
Here's what I see.
You're a very driven
entrepreneur, which is good.
But the trade‐off
of that ‐‐
There are just
some entrepreneurs
that are better
as solo entrepreneurs.
Right now, it's your baby.
You have your vision.
I don't think you're
ready for a partner
at this point in time.
I'm out.
I'm very sorry
to hear that.
Elizabeth, this is a mat
made of foam, okay?
An expensive mat
made out of foam.
I just think
you're gonna have
a very hard time
making money with this.
I'm out.
You know, Elizabeth,
you're very, very, very early.
There's way more you don't know
than you know today,
and you haven't shipped
a single one,
so we don't really know what
the consumer's gonna think.
It's not for me.
I'm out.
But it's not over yet.
Lori, you have been
through this.
You've created
so many products.
I really respect you
professionally
and look up to you,
so you would be
the ideal Shark partner,
and I came here to make a deal
with you, Lori.
See, I think what you've done
is beautiful.
Thank you.
I mean,
the sad thing is,
is that you can't
really protect it.
But you are first,
and it's very, very pretty.
On the flip‐side, I'm not sure
how many people buy these,
and your price point's
high.
Lori, I believe that
we can do this together.
You're Ulysses,
she's the Siren.
[ Laughter ]
Are you gonna go
into the rocks?
It's really hard,
because I do ‐‐
Lori.
I love you, and I think
it's a really smart product.
I just have to go
with my gut on
"Do I feel that this is
the right investment for me?"
And it is!
And I'm sad to say,
on this one,
I'm gonna be out.
Congrats on
your business, though.
Good luck,
Elizabeth.
I didn't make a deal.
I didn't think
it would come down to this.
I have worked myself to the bone
to get to this stage.
I really thought
it would have worked out,
so it's just kind of surprising.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next into the the Tank
is a convenient way
to clean up on the go.
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Chris Crawford.
And I'm Eric Fagan.
And we're two surfers
from San Diego, California,
here today to offer you
5% for $250,000
for a bite out of our company,
RinseKit.
What if I told you
that we have a product
that everyone could use
but nobody knows it exists yet?
The RinseKit is the ultimate
portable shower system,
and it revolutionizes the way
you go outside and have fun.
Basically, every RinseKit
comes with a little adapter
that we give you
to attach to your hose bib.
This nozzle right here
is on a quick neck,
so all you got to do
is attach it, plug it in,
turn on your hose bib
outside your house,
and the water pressure
transfers into the RinseKit,
compresses the air,
and now you have 65 PSI
trapped inside the RinseKit.
This whole process
takes about two minutes.
It's two gallons of water.
So, once you disconnect
the RinseKit,
you hook up your nozzle,
and you get
the same water pressure
that you get out
of your garden hose.
[ Water spraying ]
And it'll spray
on this center setting
for a little over
five minutes.
And on the mist setting,
it can go
for 30 to 45 minutes.
And also, the top comes off,
so you can stand on it,
shower off, and go right into
your flip‐flops at the beach.
Yeah, we tried
to think of everything.
So, this is just
the ultimate portable shower
when you're going outside ‐‐
camping, fishing, hunting.
So, Chris, what's
the number‐one reason
people are gonna
buy this?
Well, the reason I invented it
was for surfing.
I would get in my car,
I'd be all salty, sandy.
My seatbelt would get
all gunked up.
It wouldn't reel up.
And then we found out
there was all sorts
of other uses for it
beyond that.
I mean, if you're gonna
go camping, you know,
to be able to rinse off
your dishes on the spot,
rinsing off the kids...
You know,
with the mist setting,
you know, half‐an‐hour
of cooling the kids off
at the soccer game
is huge.
And what ‐‐ what's
your background?
I used to own
my own pool business.
You know, it helped me
with hydraulics,
understanding plumbing and
electrical and engineering
and all that stuff.
And what about you, Eric?
What do you do?
So, I actually help
with the sales
and the operations
of the business.
My background is running
Global and Sales and Operations
for companies.
Are you an investor
or are you an agent?
We have equity in it.
Who's "we"?
Me and my partners.
So, Chris,
break it up for us.
You started it.
How much money did you put in?
Who owns what?
So, I sold
my entire pool company
and put it all into this.
How much?
I sold it for $75,000,
and I used that to kind of
fund me so I'd have a living,
and then I talked
to one of my clients.
He was like, "This is cool,
I'm gonna help you,"
so he got 10%
to come on board,
and he gave me $75,000.
From there, we're like,
"Okay, this is starting
to get some traction."
How many years ago
was this?
It was
about three years ago.
Any debt?
$550,000.
‐Oh!
‐Whoa. Okay.
‐Yippee‐yi‐yo‐ki‐yay!
Herjavec:
So, walk us through it.
Chris,
how much do you own?
I have about 60%
right now.
And...?
Well, I'm a partner
in a company,
and our company owns
10% of the business.
Eric,
what are the sales today?
Just under $800,000.
Wow.
And what do you sell it for?
What's your margin?
$89.99 retail.
Okay.
Wholesale's $45.
Our margins are high 40s.
What are you gonna make
in this calendar year?
We're gonna sell $2.1 million
to $2.3 million.
We're gonna make
about 5% EBITDA,
so it'll be around $100,000
in net profit.
‐So, why so low in EBITDA?
‐Yeah.
I mean, with those
kinds of margins,
you guys should
be making more.
Vesting heavy in the marketing,
you know?
We really wanted to put
our flag in the ground
and say "Here we are."
And how are you
marketing it,
and how much are you
spending on marketing?
We're spending about 10%
of our gross revenue
on marketing.
‐Your company owns 10%.
‐Yep.
So, are you making, also,
a sales commission off of this?
We are.
What's your
commission on it?
It varies depending
on the discount the
account receives ‐‐
anywhere
from 5% to 8% to 10%.
Cuban: So,
the big question is ‐‐
Where can you get
your EBITDA to ‐‐
or, actually,
your net margins to?
So, the target
for next year,
we'd be in the high
single digits for EBITDA,
and then the year after that,
in the mid‐teens.
‐So, give me an example.
‐So, what changes?
So you're marketing is a
percentage of sales?
That's a $4 million year,
right?
5‐ish.
What do you think you'll make
on the $5 million model?
$5 million, we're gonna make
about $400,000 and change.
You're gonna make
$400,000 pre‐tax,
$300,000 after tax?
Ish.
You're basically asking me
to value it
at 18 times
sales two years from now.
I mean,
I'm just getting back
to a question
that you got to answer.
Sure.
You're very expensive.
Cuban: Guys, I think
it's a brilliant product.
It obviously
fills a need,
but there are
certain outlets
that really are
your core customers.
Yeah.
They don't really match with,
historically, my businesses,
and it's certainly not tech,
so I'm gonna say I'm out.
‐Okay.
‐Thank you.
‐Thanks, Mark. Yeah.
‐Mm‐hmm.
I'm really struggling
with the valuation,
I got to tell you.
I'm gonna have to wait years
to get my money back.
‐Mm‐hmm.
‐It depends
on who wants
to buy the company.
But that's my only exit.
I give you $250,000 for 5%.
You're gonna have to grow
this thing geometrically
before the distributions
ever pay me back.
Let's be realistic here.
Yeah.
I think it's reasonable that
this gets to $10 million, okay?
You've already proven it,
and you've got retailers
that want to do it.
You're gonna make $800,000
on that, pre‐tax,
so after tax, $600K.
And I own 5%.
I make $30,000
three years from now
on my $250,000 investment,
assuming
everything goes right.
Well, what if the business
is sold for $20 million,
and you have 5% equity?
‐Is that ‐‐ that doesn't even ‐‐
‐How do see what you're selling?
Because it is, right now,
one product.
How do see
you're selling this
for a large amount of money
down the road?
So, that's
a great question.
So, we're building
a category at retail,
going
into specialty retail
and creating a category
they never had before
that allows them
to make money.
We can create an ecosystem
around that.
We can add
other products.
We've done a lot of stuff
with the lid ‐‐
you know,
holding trays ‐‐
and there are ways
to wash your dishes on it.
We've got heaters,
we've got field‐fill kits,
wheels, shower poles.
Can I say something,
though, too?
Like, when we built the forecast
models for this business,
we didn't include
any big‐box.
I mean, could you not
see this product
sitting in Target
on an end cap
for a mom to walk by
and like,
"Oh, my gosh,
I can rinse my kids off
after I go
to the beach."
‐Well, Chris, I like it.
‐[ Chuckles ]
I mean, I think
it's a great idea.
Thank you.
As a fellow surfer,
I see the need.
I love the need with the kids.
Lots of lots of markets.
The only part
I didn't like, Eric,
was it's always dangerous
when you build a company
that has to have an exit.
And that is the fundamental
problem with the deal.
At 5%, if it sells,
I'm good to go.
‐Right.
‐Mm‐hmm.
If it doesn't,
you get sales agency commission,
I get nothing.
Make us an offer.
I'll make you an offer.
I'll give you
the $250,000,
but I don't get an agency fee
along the way, so I want 20%.
‐Oof.
‐Mm. That's hard.
That's twice
what my whole company owns.
[ Laughs ]
It's a lot.
You know, I don't think
his offer's unreasonable.
I was gonna say
your business is worth about
2 million bucks right now,
and if there's no exit,
I don't want to wait eight years
to get my money back.
It's too much risk.
I'd do the $250,000 debt.
You're already used
to putting debt on.
You've got $500K.
And I want 5% equity
for taking the risk.
I don't think it's a good time
for you do that.
Cuban: I agree.
I agree with you.
That's 20%.
That's very dilutive.
20% is a lot.
I mean, that dilutes Chris
significantly.
What are you guys gonna do?
You've got two offers.
[ Chuckles ]
I mean...
I'm gonna make you an offer.
I'd like ‐‐
You're gonna make an offer?
‐There you go.
‐Yeah.
What's your offer,
Lori?
Well!
I'm gonna make you an offer
that's kind of like you.
I want to be like Eric.
$250,000 as debt for 5%,
but I want the same royalties
that you get on what I bring.
You're asking for more
than Kevin did, basically.
‐Of course she is.
‐Yeah, she is.
She's expensive,
but, you know, she brings it.
I bring that value.
She only gets paid
for what she kills.
I know your history. I know what
you're capable of doing.
‐Chris, Eric.
‐Yeah.
I'm not a loan‐shark kind
of guy.
Yeah.
I'm an equity guy.
There's a lot of noise here,
and there's two debt deals.
[ Chuckles ]
I like my equity deal.
I understand
the equity is a lot.
Mm‐hmm.
What if I went to $350,000
for the 20%?
It's more
the equity that it is...
Uh‐oh.
...than the amount of,
you know, cash coming in.
‐Cash, yeah.
‐Yeah.
To be honest,
I don't want to see Chris
dilute below
a majority.
I mean, this is his brainchild,
this is his baby.
He built his life
around it.
His wife's a schoolteacher.
They have a 2‐month‐old.
You're gonna have to do
a debt deal if you want that.
You can create a structure
where he has the voting.
All right, guys, look.
You've got offers on the table.
You've got
to make a decision.
♪♪
Narrator: One Shark is out.
Chris and Eric have
three offers on the table
for their portable shower,
RinseKit.
O'Leary: Okay, so you've got
three offers.
$350,000 from Robert
for 20% straight equity.
Lori, $250,000 for 5% equity,
but it's debt,
and she wants to be paid
the same sales commission
for the territories
and products she brings in
that you
mutually agree on.
I'm willing to do the deal,
$250,000 straight debt.
I want 5% equity,
as well.
Three offers.
What are you gonna do?
So, honestly,
selling debt
isn't something we really
want to do right now.
I mean, we have access
to capital.
You know, a lot of people
can go find any VC,
but it's totally different
when you have a Shark.
Agreed.
I totally agree.
A completely different story.
So, it's not
apples to apples.
Right.
Yeah, but you're offering debt.
You're not offering equity.
Well, but if you want
to keep control,
you have to take debt.
Well, but we also know ‐‐
You can't
give 20% away.
But if you look
at our balance sheet,
we already have enough debt.
What's that?
Guys, you have
to make a decision.
Hold on.
I have an offer.
$250,000
for 7.5% straight equity.
But I also want commissions
on the retailers that
I sell this product into.
Now, I have relationships
with several of them.
I'm on the board
with PECO Foundation.
I'll also sell to Home Depot,
Tractor Supply Company, HSN,
Walmart, Target, and all the
other ones that we want to go.
Is that debt,
or is that equity?
Aw. He's copying my deal,
my original deal.
No, but he's for equity.
He did it for equity, not debt.
‐Ooh.
‐I'm straight equity, 7.5%.
He stole your structure,
but made it
more attractive for them.
It's a great offer.
It's a pretty good
offer.
‐Great offer.
‐It's a very good offer.
What do you want to do?
You have to make a decision.
I mean...
Anything else you guys
want to say last‐minute?
[ Laughs ]
Anybody else?
Any other counters?
Mark,
you want back in?
Nope.
Daymond...
that's a great offer.
We accept it.
‐All right.
‐Yeah!
‐Yeah.
‐Congratulations, guys.
Love it!
Thank you, man.
Love it, love it.
Thanks, Daymond.
Appreciate it.
You got it.
Awesome.
♪♪
Daymond, I want to borrow
the jet on Tuesday,
if that's okay.
Seriously.
We really like
surfing Nicaragua,
so as soon as we can
get down there...
‐You stole my idea.
‐That's a rich offer, Daymond.
‐I know.
‐You little weasel.
You basically offered them
what they were looking for.
Hey, listen,
at any given time,
a Shark can turn into
a bottom‐feeding catfish.
Narrator: In Season 4,
Trew Quackenbush and Corey Ward
made a deal
with Barbara Corcoran
for their grilled‐cheese
restaurant franchise,
"Tom + Chee."
Everything in my bones
is saying
this is a runaway hit.
Let's see what
they're doing now.
Today, we're hosting
our annual franchisee convention
in Cincinnati, Ohio.
We have franchisees
from 31 locations
representing 15 states.
Ward: We're gonna see
the new menu.
We're gonna taste
the new food.
And we've even
invited Barbara out
to be our keynote speaker.
Everybody welcome
Barbara Corcoran.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Corcoran: I'm here
to share my experience,
because I've walked
in their shoes
and I've build a business
from the ground up.
It's all about the people.
Find people
who know how to smile
and make that customer feel
like they're the ends
of the earth for them.
We invited Barbara here to
really inspire our franchisees
so they get an opportunity
to learn from her experiences.
They're gonna be able to
come out of this re‐invigorated
and ready to push
their businesses ahead.
[ Applause ]
Right here is where, in 2009,
where Tom + Chee got its start.
Seven years ago, we started out
in a tent in Fountain Square.
I don't think we would have ever
imagined one brick‐and‐mortar,
let alone
31 locations today.
When we first went
on "Shark Tank,"
we had
$1.5 million in sales.
Today, $47 million in sales,
and we've created over 500 jobs.
We never thought
we'd grow this big,
and it's thanks to you guys,
and, thank you, Barbara.
This has been awesome.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, let's eat!
Come on, guys.
[ All cheering ]
Tom + Chee is one
of my most successful
"Shark Tank" investments
because Corey and Trew
had a huge dream,
and they worked like crazy
to make it happen.
Look at us!
3 1/2 years later,
and look how big
their business is.
What does everybody think
of the new menu stuff?
You never know where
life's gonna take you.
One day, you could be
flipping burgers on a grill.
The next day, you could be
running a grilled‐cheese empire.
All: Tom + Chee!
♪♪
My name is Richard Elden,
and I live in Manhattan Beach,
California.
I was born and raised in London,
and I lived there
up until my parents' divorce
when I was 9 years old.
My mother decided
to move us to California
to seek a better life.
This is the land of opportunity.
If you have the passion
and you don't take no
for an answer,
this is the country to be in.
My big break came
when California decided
to pass legislation
to ban plastic bags.
How's it going today?
Good. How are you?
Big retail started
to take notice,
and my company has become
a real success.
Woman: I'm glad you're
working so hard, Richard.
Do it
while you're young.
I have tons of orders,
which is a great thing,
but I never seem to have
enough money to keep up.
If I can't fill these orders,
my competitors will,
and I can't let that happen.
I need money.
I need lots of money.
I need it now.
I am dedicating to making this
a huge success.
I know I can do it
if I get an investment
from the Sharks.
♪♪
[ Sighs ]
[ Groans ]
[ Chuckles ]
♪♪
[ Exhales sharply ]
Richard Elden here from
Manhattan Beach, California,
and I'm asking for $350,000
for 5% equity in my company,
Dbest Products!
Oh, man.
We are your one‐stop shop
for all your cart needs.
Now, let me show you
why everybody calls me
"The Cart Guy."
Smart Cart.
It weights less than 3 pounds.
It holds 110 pounds.
It folds to only 2 inches.
Wow.
It's got a convenient
front pocket.
It envelopes,
because it's waterproof.
It's got an ergonomic curvature
in the handle
because it allows you pull
more weight with less effort,
and it's got
a convenient strap handle
to go up and down the stairs,
in and out of the car,
or in and out of the overhead
compartment on the plane.
Now, we have a ton
of different Smart Carts.
We even have
a pet Smart Cart.
[ Both chuckle ]
It's luggage‐style
maneuverability
in a pet carrier.
I've also developed
the Trolley Dolly.
This guy has seven different
pockets and compartments.
The back slides off,
and it turns into a dolly.
It holds 150 pounds!
[ Laughs ]
Carts are not just
for groceries anymore, guys.
That's our
cooler Smart Cart.
So, you use them
for coolers today,
use them for storage.
They even have seats today,
so you take them out
for picnics.
We even have a stair climber.
Look at that.
That's cool. Wow.
That goes up and down
the stairs,
in and out of the car.
Now, I need money,
but I don't just want
any money.
[ Laughter ]
I don't just want any money.
I want smart money.
I want a smart partner
that can help me
get into more retail
and more markets.
So, who's gonna
be a smart Shark
and join me
with my Smart Cart?
Okay.
$350,000 for 5%.
Very good.
That's right.
Should I beat you up now,
or should we wait?
‐Uh, no, beat me up now.
‐Okay.
Before you cart him out,
tell us what you're selling.
I mean...
Sales.
Sales this year
are already $5 million.
‐Whoa!
‐Oh, wow.
‐Yes, yes.
‐Okay.
We're projected to do between
$7 million and $8 million
by the end of the year.
We did only $2.5 million
last year...
Where are you
selling all this?
... so you can see
the growth.
Retail or online
or both?
Both.
We sell into Bed Bath & Beyond,
Staples, Hobby Lobby...
You also have
$8 million ‐‐
You're gonna project
$8 million in sales.
So, what are you
here for?
Well, uh ‐‐
‐He needs money!
‐Yeah, I need money!
‐Why do you need money?
Okay, so,
from $2.5 million
to $7 million, $8 million,
I have to fund
the inventory myself.
Why?
Because it's my company,
I'm 100% owner,
but I'm not
desperate enough
to pay those ridiculous
interest rates.
What are they
charging you ‐‐ 18%?
‐Uh, it's more because ‐‐
‐Why not pay the interest?
Is your margin
not high enough?
Richard, tell us, what's
your blended gross margin
and what's your profit?
Blended gross margin is 50%.
Now, what is your profit,
pre‐tax?
So, last year, for example,
we did $2.5 million.
Profit was $250,000.
But here's the thing ‐‐
Herjavec: No, but hang on.
Richard, why was
your profit only 10%
if your gross margin
is 50%?
Yeah.
So, we do trade shows.
I have payroll.
I have to pay for my warehouse.
Richard,
let me ask you this.
Yes.
Today,
you get the $350,000.
Yes.
What happens tomorrow?
That's what
he's been saying!
He needs more money
'cause he's growing!
That's right.
And he wants you
to finance it!
Okay, but ‐‐ but,
if you finance it,
you're gonna make the interest,
you're gonna be my partner.
I've got investments
such as ‐‐
5% ‐‐ Look, Richard,
5% is not being a partner.
‐Right.
‐Okay.
So let's open it up.
Let's go bigger.
Guys, I have an order here
not part of my valuation
for almost $3 million
from QVC.
Greiner: From who?
QVC.
And it's not part
of my valuation.
Because I was gonna say,
you know, I'm watching this,
and I've seen so many products
like this.
Those are probably
my products.
Richard, can we
see the order?
It's hard to believe,
I get it.
It's doing very, very well.
How many times
have you been on QVC?
We have several shows
a month.
I've been working with QVC
personally
for probably 16 to 17 years.
I've owned my company
for 15 years.
Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait.
So you've been
in business
almost 15 years
with Dbest, right?
Yes, yes.
What all of a sudden changed
to go from, you know, nothing
to $2.7 million
last year?
I started the company...
with the Quik Cart, okay?
This sold
on the TV shopping networks
for 8 1/2 years.
2010,
I developed the Smart Cart.
So you decide
you need a new product,
you come up with
a product that works.
Well, the reason
I came out with it
is because, in California,
they had legislation
banning plastic bags,
and I knew at that point
I wanted to develop a cart
that weighed less, held more,
folded thinner.
John:
Is this your biggest‐selling
product that you've had
through your course
of being an entrepreneur?
Smart Cart?
Yes. Yes.
Because the way we're looking
at you is that, you know,
you're here for basically
somebody to help finance
not only this,
but ongoing orders
and grow the business
off of that.
Right
I'm gonna make you
an offer.
I'll give you
the $350,000 for 15%,
and then I'll take you
into Samsung in my deal.
That means
warehousing, shipping,
distribution, returns ‐‐
everything else like that.
So, when get $1 billion
in orders, we can ship it.
So you'll provide
all the financing?
Sam‐‐
O'Leary: So, let me ‐‐ let me
chime in here.
I'll do $350,000
in a line of credit.
You draw it down
as you want it.
It's 18%.
And I'm gonna take
5% equity.
So, I'm your partner ‐‐
I'm an equity partner.
But you haven't
solved his problem.
So ‐‐ What's that?
You haven't solved
his problem.
Right.
Look, you're telling me
this cash won't help you?
You can draw it all down
and keep it out there.
Yeah, but he'll
draw it down like that
because just his QVC orders
are gonna eat that up.
Greiner: Who sells
your product?
Well, then, Mark,
you give him a deal.
I'm just bringing up
the facts.
Herjavec: Richard,
let me clear things up.
Yes.
You ever watch
those old commercials
where they have a bouncing ball
over the words?
Yes.
That's what
you remind me of.
‐Is that good or bad?
‐I can't follow it.
Richard, my friend,
I can't follow
the bouncing balls.
Okay.
16 years in business,
this product, that product.
Okay. I've been in business
a long time.
I'm out.
Okay, okay.
Cheers.
You know what, Richard?
You know you're in my world.
Right, right.
So...I will give you
an offer.
$350,000, 15%.
Lori, no ‐‐
Let me just summarize the deals
you've gotten, all right?
Look, I know my value.
I know different it will be
for you for QVC.
Lori, you're
underselling yourself.
Mark,
let her do what she wants,
unless you're gonna
bring a deal.
♪♪
Narrator: One Shark is out.
Richard has three offers
on the table
for his specialty cart business,
Smart Cart.
Greiner: You know what, Richard,
I will give you an offer.
$350,000, 15%.
Lori, no ‐‐
Let me just summarize the deals
you've gotten, all right?
Look, I know my value.
I know how different it will be
for you for QVC.
Lori, you're
underselling yourself.
Mark,
let her do what she wants,
unless you're gonna
bring a deal.
Wait,
let me hear Mark.
Okay, if we did
a deal together, right,
he needs capital.
Yeah.
The big question
isn't the $350,000.
The big question is
what comes next,
and at what
interest rate?
You know
this business.
I don't know
this business at all.
I have no problem doing
a $1 million line of credit,
$2 million.
So if you think
it's legit,
$350,000 for 20%
and a minimum of $2 million
in financing
at 15% simple interest.
I'll do that deal.
You get what you haven't had
and what you really need,
which is an immediate access
to liquid capital.
So $350,000 for 20%?
Equity, yeah.
But the difference is ‐‐
‐That values my company at ‐‐
‐What's he saying ‐‐
No, but you're looking
at that wrong.
O'Leary: No, he isn't.
He can look at it
any way he wants.
Wait, wait.
Hold on, guys.
So, you're saying
that you have ‐‐
you have orders
you can't fulfill...
Uh‐huh.
...stores you
can't go into.
Uh‐huh.
So even though
you take a smaller ‐‐
you have 80% now
instead of 95% ‐‐
Richard,
it's simpler than that.
Yeah, so it values your company
at $1.5 million.
$1.5 million, and I'm valued
at $7 million to $8 million.
Yeah, but listen.
Let me ‐‐
Yeah. You're worth
at least $4 million,
so you're giving them
too much equity.
Let me just
tell you again.
How much sales
do you have
that you can't
fulfill right now?
Sales you can't take now because
you don't have the cash?
So, as of this moment,
it's about $1 million.
So now you give up
that extra 20%.
The question is, does the value
of your company increase
by more than 25%
because now you can
take that capital?
Not at $1 million
in sales.
That doesn't work,
my friend.
That's what
you have to decide.
Well, but listen.
Then you're with me,
so then your orders
will double,
triple, quadruple.
I like the structure.
I don't like ‐‐
So you're gonna be selling
so much more.
You're gonna need
so much more money.
I would like it
if you could consider
a lower equity position,
so that we can come to ‐‐
What equity
would you want?
Elden: Um...
[ Sighs ]
I would either like more money
for the higher equity or...
Make a counter.
Don't make it
more confusing.
Okay.
Let me help you
with that counter.
Yes, please.
I'm out.
[ Sighs ]
How about
$700,000 for 10%,
and...
I'm seeing a head shake.
Um...
Herjavec: Richard,
the longer you stand there ‐‐
You already lost one offer.
You could lose both.
$700,000 ‐‐
To who?
To my dream team over here.
For 15%, and have
the credit facility available.
I think 15% for both of us
is tough.
Okay, so,
can you counter?
‐No.
‐Because what I said was ‐‐
They said no, Richard.
They said no.
O'Leary:
You really got to decide.
Neither of these deals
are gonna change.
What are you
going to do?
[ Sighs, claps ]
Let me say thank you very much
for your offer.
‐Thank you.
‐It was very creative.
It's a once‐in‐a‐lifetime
opportunity,
and I recognize that.
It's more equity
than I want to give up,
but the $2 million in financing
and more if I need it, right?
It's basically ‐‐
As long as those
are legit PO's...
Right. Legit PO's
from legit retailers...
Right.
It's way more equity
for not enough money.
What am I gonna do?
Mark and Lori...
Let's do it.
‐Ah!
‐Mazel tov!
[ Indistinct cheering ]
John:
That's a tough one!
[ Sighs ]
Oh!
Oh, my gosh.
[ Laughter ]
‐Congrats, buddy.
‐Okay. Thanks, guys.
Cheers.
Brutal.
Just brutal.
Made a deal!
Whoo!
Aah!
Yeah!
I feel unbelievable.
Mark and Lori were exactly the
two Sharks I were looking for,
and they came in,
and they were excited.
I'm excited.
We're all excited!
Whoo!
[ Laughs ]
♪♪